hello friends and welcome back to rapid
fire language journey today we're
exploring the question should you wait
or should you speak from day one when it
comes to learning a language from
scratch now there's a lot of schools of
thought and there is no
one-size-fits-all solution but here's my
piece of advice follow your intuition
speaking a language from day one depends
on it or not depends on a number of
factors depends on the learner depends
on their background their mindset but
also depends on their target language so
if you feel like speaking a language
from the very beginning then go for it
especially when your target language is
similar to yours there's a lot of
advantages to that because speaking with
human beings also gives you
the extra motivation you need to keep
going if on the other hand the language
is a little bit distant and more
difficult then you might wait a little
bit more if you want to know more about
how to learn languages better faster
more efficiently and with more fun
please check out my channel over and out